hey everyone this is jeremy shiffling
with khan academy
thanks so much for joining us this
afternoon um you're in for a very
special treat today
because we have khan academy ambassador
and all-star middle teacher shalom with
us today
who's been using khan academy for almost
a decade basically since khan
um sal khan himself started making the
videos shalom has been with us using it
in his classroom so
if you're ever curious about how do you
get started with khan academy for remote
learning
how do you specialize and target your
content for your middle school students
shalom is the person to speak to and
he's happy to share his expertise today
so that being said before we get
shalom's background here
i want to remind you that the first part
of the session we focused on the most
common questions we received
and shalom will talk through how to get
started and how to focus your energies
with khan academy
and then we'll open it up for the final
half for questions from the audience
so if you ever want to ask a question
just go to the questions section of the
go to webinar control panel
and we'll take those in the order
they're received so shalom
welcome and thank you so much for
joining us today it's uh very nice to be
here with everybody
and just to sort of give folks a sense
of where you're coming from tell us a
little bit about where you teach
who you teach and what your experience
with khan has been okay i'm a
seventh grade math teacher in uh ocean
township new jersey
uh teaching is a second career for me i
actually worked on wall street for six
years
um and decided to make a switch and i've
been teaching middle school
ever since so here i am in monmouth
county new jersey
very cool and so tell us like even
before this crisis started
why have you been a con user in your
classroom
um at about the 2010-2011 school year
a friend of mine had told me about it um
and
i had heard about this khan academy
videos thing but she told me oh no no it
has exercises so i was really drawn to
the exercises
back then they had to get um either
seven in a row or ten in a row right to
level up
and i was like this is how we learn uh
everything
so i primarily i didn't have computers
back then i used it um
initially for extra credit um
but i i continue to use it to this day
it's my primary source of practice
problems for students i use others but
it's my primary source um and what
you know i love the fact that students
can go at their own pace they're not
it really it allows them to learn what
they want at their
um at their level um and
it provides such good data for me as a
teacher to decide when to intervene
what to intervene what trends there are
things like that
very cool and so obviously you could
probably give an entire
three-hour lecture on how to set up khan
academy during normal times
i really could the times we live in are
very abnormal all of a sudden
if you are an educator out there a
middle school teacher who is struggling
to get started
with remote learning basically yesterday
and their district is saying hey you've
got to
roll something out for your students
obviously number one our hearts go out
to you
but number two what kind of like really
concrete tips would you give
to that educator who wants to get
started immediately okay
um first of all i'm very fortunate my
students are conditioned
on how to use khan academy so there's a
and i know it's scary to oh my god how
am i going to start with something new
so my recommendation
is is to go through some exercises
as a student you know answer them
yourself
but make sure they are review exercises
start with something you know that the
kids would know
start small assign a few skills for them
and then just
at that point dive in meaning you assign
it to them you tell them
here go do this by friday and let them
work
and then take a look at the data that
comes in take a look at
what students are working on um are they
uh getting them correct are they not um
so you want to start small because you
you don't want to overwhelm the kids
with a bunch of stuff which is why
i think for right now it would be good
to start with review
uh but then once you get started
make sure to look at all the reports try
to understand it you know i know it's so
hard to see the forest through the trees
um but uh that would be my big piece of
advice
and here's where i'm gonna give you a
shout out jeremy uh a few weeks ago you
did a
workshop and you talked about adding he
goes why don't you add yourself as a
coach to your own account and i think
that was
actually something i had never thought
to do you know considering the amount of
time i've spent using khan
and by doing that i started seeing the
same um
report notifications that the students
would see you know
here's something your teacher assigned
you i started getting email
notifications
so you you kind of by adding yourself
as a coach to your own learner side of
the account
because every account can be a learner
and a and a coach account
um it it really kind of helped me
understand
i i already kind of knew what they saw
but it really let me
kind of put it in my face to see what
the students are seeing when i assign
them things
very cool so just to recap those three
main steps sounds like number one
just start searching around khan academy
playing the role of a student
what does it feel like to look at a
video what does it feel like to do an
exercise get some hints
once you see one that you're really
excited about maybe just start by
assigning a single assignment at a time
just to sort of dip your toes into the
water and get your students feeling
comfortable
and to really understand what it looks
like from the student lens come down to
your student section
get your class code and then under your
learner home
you can find the section called teachers
at the very bottom and add yourself
to your own classroom you'll now see
those notifications that shalom talked
about
so you understand exactly what it feels
like to be in your student shoes
yeah and the other thing too is is in
this um
the time that we're in the videos you
know tend to take a little longer
i would just start at first with the
exercises um you know
this is just practical advice um so that
you can quickly see oh is this something
i'd want my students doing
um and if it is right at the top of the
screen
if you pick an exercise right now can
you just pick one and show everybody how
they can assign it to their students
right from the top of the screen
yeah tell me like a common like skill
you might be teaching in your classroom
right now shalom if we were back in
school
um well this time of year um i'm doing
some geometry with my advanced class
so if you go to seventh grade geometry
so let's just go to
uh area of a circle second one there
so click the practice button see this is
you're in the student view
the students have to answer seven
questions and you say wait a minute i
really like this question up here so at
the top
there's a sign to all right you can
assign it to
multiple classes you can assign it to
individual students as long as it's for
one class only
if you have multiple classes it's going
to assign it to every student in the
class
i prefer to do different questions or
you can also assign the same questions
to everybody um different questions the
way i go
and then you can set a due date now this
will come up on their
um learner dashboard but
this right here will not come up on
google classroom that's something
teachers i know
you can link your class to google
classrooms to get your roster
um into khan academy but assignments
don't automatically go
out to google classroom and i'm hoping
that they are working on
changing that in the future yeah i'll
just mention on that point
if you ever have feedback for us about
something you'd love to see in the
product
just go right up to your name in the
upper right hand corner click the help
button
and then come to the section called
report a problem and say hey
i've got a really great feature idea
that would make things much much better
i'll actually paste this in to the chat
section
so you can let us know if you have
problems or ideas
you want us to consider okay so that is
um sort of getting started with sort of
checking it out
what are some of the challenges that you
anticipate that teachers will face in
the next few weeks shalom i know we have
a lot of things on our shoulders right
now but if you think about khan academy
in particular
where do you see new teachers run into
issues and how can they sort of
preempt those best they can okay
my biggest challenge with khan academy
has always been
getting students to buy into the growth
mindset aspect of it
you know the the it's not just here's
five problems do them great you got four
wrong let's move on to the next topic
it's really designed to have the kids
work until they show levels of
proficiency
so um two things that i make all my
students and parents do
at the beginning of the year is i make
them watch the you can learn anything
video
um and also there's a about a five
six minute or so ted talk um
by angela lee duckworth on grit
um so it's kind of to get them set
and by the way she's she talks about how
she was a seventh grade teacher and how
um you know perseverance and all these
things
to get students in the mindset of you're
not gonna get everything right
um you're gonna make mistakes along the
way
and that it's okay as long as you keep
going those are the two things i think
that are
are the biggest challenges that i've had
you know and uh
i've had some tough times especially in
my earlier years with
with you know parents complaining about
how
frustrated their child is but since i've
started doing that i've gotten much
better
appreciation from the parents and from
the students that
struggling is okay i always say why is
it okay to be terrible
when you first play an instrument i mean
you don't you don't see somebody pick up
the flute and they're playing it and
they sound great they sound awful
right and why is it not acceptable in
math to be bad at something at first so
that's my uh first thing um
also another challenge is the amount of
content can be overwhelming
it really really can but thankfully
every if you click on courses there for
me jeremy
right you guys
um you will see the courses
are aligned with the common core
standards
which you know um
uh by grade so if you go down i'm
looking at your screen right now
first grade second grade third grade
fourth grade so you can go in there and
find
the exercises by standard there's also a
common core map
which is i think it's okay
it's great for high school teachers but
k to eight the standards are really
well aligned by grade um so
you can or you can there's the common
core map you know it shows grade one
there's 28 unique skills and 605
questions and so on and so forth
um this is a different view but i prefer
the other view where you go into the
grade itself
but i know it's overwhelming to see all
that information but if you narrow it
down
find exercises you like try them out and
assign them to your students
and then just see where it goes from
there
great great advice so really sort of
start with a little bit of inspiration
setting the bar high letting your
students you know that you believe in
them
even when the challenge is so strong
right now and then number two
finding the stuff that really brings
them back to that sense of normalcy
like hey we would have been covering
this right now and so we're going to
keep going ahead
and not give up um last question before
we opened up for more questions from the
audience
is if you think a couple weeks ahead you
know the teachers have taken your advice
for getting started they've made a
couple of assignments
and now maybe the pressure is really on
to deliver kind of
classroom-like instruction on a regular
basis and really take the most of tools
of khan academy
are there any more advanced tips or
techniques from your middle school
experience
that you would recommend for a middle
school educator out there
i'm sorry i was coughing there um
you know i think that can you repeat the
end of that question because i coughed
at the end
oh no no um yeah just just thinking
ahead like
i know personally in my kid's own
district here there's a lot of
discussion right now about going from
pure sort of like keep the lights on day
in and day out
to how do we actually have you know
clear plans
clear structures in place to mimic as
much classroom instruction as possible
if a teacher is facing that kind of
challenge over the next few weeks or
months
like what can they do on khan academy to
go above and beyond just one assignment
what turns it into a system into a
process okay
um first of all this is
tough for people to to wrap their heads
around but
if you are okay if you can get yourself
okay with students working at their own
pace
right if you have them start to work
through a unit
um can you pull up before the the
session started we talked about the uh
the mastery point system okay so um
that's kind of small on my screen i
don't know if i would look on other
people's screens but
okay perfect zero points means a student
so
this is all this all has to do with
exercise sets so
zero points means either a student has
i'm trying to point my mouse but i'm
guessing they either have
never started it no level or they've
attempted it if you see the little
diamond in the bottom right corner
that means they've gotten less than 70
percent on that problem set
then if the student gets uh at least 70
percent they get to 50 points
which is familiar and then if they
get 100 in that problem set they get
80 points and they're proficient right
and the last 20 points they can get
mastered they have to do one of two ways
either
by taking a unit test on khan academy or
by
answering them correctly on what's
called the mastery challenge all right
if you stay to the students um let's
pick a
let's go to geomet uh seventh grade
geometry or seventh grade anything
and you asked the students okay you know
what start at the beginning
by the way i wouldn't necessarily start
with geometry it's not the
uh let's do negative numbers addition
subtraction here let's use that
and say to the students all right get
started
all right if you go down you're gonna
have to scroll to the there's the first
skill
signs of sums they're not actually
they're gonna they're gonna see
instead of uh mastered they're gonna see
a little blue button there that says
start and that's how they can get to the
exercise
and then say okay go from there to the
next one adding negative numbers
right and the points system that i just
discussed is on the right side there now
the
your account or whoever's account this
is has already mastered all those
so it's kind of um not the best example
because you know uh
this person already mastered all these
but if you have the students start at
the first skill
in negative numbers and work their way
through
and say listen i i just want you to work
30 minutes a day and try to you know
watch videos do exercises see how you do
and you use that point system in the
reporting that you get
as well and that point system helps you
determine
what it is that students uh need more
help with
and do you want to talk very briefly
about these progress reports
just because i think that'll help folks
really draw the connection between what
the students are seeing and doing and
what the teacher is
responding with okay so let's go to
um solving equations and inequalities so
if you click on that
right and you scroll down a little bit
all right not started right now there
are eight students that are
not started and that's their names right
there
that's the zero points attempted there's
one student
that's um attempted means they got less
than 70 percent
familiar we have no students in that
category so those
are students that have seventy percent
but less than a hundred percent
proficient is a student that did the
exercise and they got all the questions
right
so they got a hundred percent they moved
to proficient and uh
looks like megan um she
eventually answered the question correct
on a unit test or did a mastery
challenge and she got those last 20
points
and that's where she gets the um the
mastered
so the point system that i talked about
before is
related it that's on the student side
what they can see
this is on the teacher side what you can
see so if you
ask your students to start on a unit and
just say just just go with it here take
take whatever minutes a day and go with
it you'll start getting this report to
populate and you'll see who's
who's getting it and who's not um and
that this is what i do in my class
during the regular year
i know it's kind of tough to do that or
to even think about doing that in this
time but
this is actually the most meaningful
part of the website for me
uh is that students are working at their
own pace and and
i tell the kids just because you know um
you're struggling with something or your
friend is struggling with something but
you're not why should i give you
homework on the same topic every day
um so this might be the perfect test
case for doing something like that
yeah i mean it's hard to find silver
linings right now but if ever there was
a moment in american education
when we could actually try to serve each
student where they are this might be
that one with tools like this
listen ideally i'd be working below
grade level
and and having my kids work their way up
um
but you know i'm still responsible for
grade level assessments and grades and
things like that
so this is a time where a lot of people
can kind of experiment with hey you know
what i think this is the best way my
students can learn and let me let me
just try it
um so cool well amazing
amazing advice shalom i think you've got
folks a lot to get started with already
let's dive into the more specific
questions coming from the audience
starting with a great one from janus so
janice talk
is talking a little bit about the
experience that students have of doing
these exercises
and she says what strategy shalom have
you found effective
in getting kids to self-help by using
those hint resources
and going back to rework and redo their
exercises to improve their understanding
one thing i've seen a lot observing
middle school students is kids don't
want to use hints
because it seems like a sign of weakness
they don't want to do it again because
it seems like oh
maybe they didn't do so well the first
time how do you overcome that
and get them to help themselves well
i'll answer in two ways number one
in class i have a rule um i
i won't answer your question unless
you've attempted the problem
and i tell the kids even if you guessed
even if it's a multiple choice question
and you guessed correctly
then raise your hand say mr lab i guess
this right but can you
explain it to me so we are almost kind
of forcing that
hand now because we're not right there
to help them
so my whole thing is encourage and this
is where the growth mindset comes in
this is where you know it's okay like i
i always use this example with my
students
um my son was eight years old taught
himself to solve a rubik's cube and made
fun of me
because i couldn't do it and then
i had to learn how to do it i mean i
couldn't i couldn't let him
you know beat me and when i did um it
took me a lot longer to learn it than it
took him so i used that as a growth
mindset lesson
i didn't give up am i stupid because it
took me longer than him
maybe but i think most people would say
wow you're a person who can solve a
rubik's cube now
um and it doesn't matter if it takes you
longer and that's the kind of thing
that i think if you can get your
students to understand that's why i like
those two videos that you can learn
anything
and the grit videos because it kind of
gets kids in that mindset so
great question harder to do than than
you know than just saying go ahead and
do this but
uh good luck janice right
yeah all right great question janet
great response shalom
um coordinator i think is going to push
us to go back a little bit and this is
important for those who are just really
getting started today
what's even required for a middle school
student to get started with a khan
academy
is all they need in email how do they
even get sort of integrated into the
system in the first place
okay the first of all if the students
if your district has a g
suite or gmail email handle
that makes it easy right there because
all you need to do
is when you go to
excuse me when you go to settings
are we in teacher tools i'm sorry yeah
yeah
okay we sync with google classroom yeah
right there sync with google classroom i
didn't know if it was in the teacher
setting or the
and you just this account's already
synced with her
with her google class this is megan's
account right so
hit sync and now that roster will be in
there
now if you don't have um
a google suite email address
in your in your district there's the
class code
now the students i always prefer they do
things with their district email address
but you can send them this class code
and they they add themselves to your
class
um the one thing i i always stress is
when students log in
if it is a google account make sure to
log in through google a lot of times
people see the login screen and they see
um an actual like place to enter a
username and password
you don't need it if it's a google
account you just link it to your google
you know account and let me actually
show what that looks like
from the um the new user standpoint so
yeah
you were coming to khan academy as a
student and you said start here
said hey i'm a learner just to be clear
your recommendation is
um better to put in uh
a class code than anything else shalom
is that right
um well no my my if you're google i
would start right there continue with
google
cool yeah do me a favor it clicks there
is it going to ask for the date of birth
anymore is that going to just
yeah so i believe it offers that based
on the fact that this person is over 13.
um but yeah you can also do google or
you can do class code
which again is pulled straight from your
classroom settings okay
great feedback correct me if i'm wrong
but the age shouldn't be
an issue if you're using it with a
school
account that's one of the reasons i also
recommend using a school account
um that's exactly right okay
okay great question for coordinating
thanks for the response to shalom
i hope i answered it gerard from ocean
township says shalom where did you get
that awesome headset
gerard gerard is messing with me gerard
is my supervisor
so uh-oh yes okay better be on your best
behavior this is my cessna pilot headset
that's pretty funny gerard
i i'm giving you props for asking that
question
[Laughter]
i think i think we're all in the market
for headsets all of a sudden so
definitely if you have a recommendation
alone let us know um
so belinda has a really good question
which is okay
we've talked a lot about the technology
but what about the sort of
teacher-student interaction piece
how would you recommend giving feedback
to students once you start getting these
progress reports
okay first of all in terms of feedback
the students are getting immediate
feedback if they answer a question right
or wrong yes the hints are not
the most exciting for them to to look at
you know but it is instant feedback and
you know i've been doing it for years
and i'm try i try to get my students
read the hints please see if you then
ask me the question
and and you know sometimes they wear you
down sometimes i they they asked me a
question i don't even ask them did you
look at the hints yet
um you know some exercises i don't
necessarily love the hints i think that
not that they're wrong
um i just don't think that they're the
most uh you know
uh simplified way of showing things
so it's the
the feedback in the classroom
is i can i can use that data
to kind of pick a group of students wow
these seven kids are struggling with
this skill let me work with them
um use that to maybe do a
a zoom conference with a small group of
kids i bought myself
this right here it's a little tablet
that i can use to write
and i make sal khan style videos myself
as kids ask me questions
you can make those if you look at
there's a certain report you can look at
and see
how many students in the class answered
it correctly or incorrectly
and and khan actually uh puts it in
order
from the most difficult to the um i'm
sorry
the one that's most frequently wrong to
uh
you know the ones that have been easiest
so
if you let's pull that up real quick so
if you see a problem you're like wow a
lot of kids are getting this wrong
and you want to do a quick video for it
in this in you know in class you would
obviously do it
here's a cl here's a question only three
students were presented with it question
seven uh two of the students got it
wrong one student got it right
my favorite part is to the right um it
shows you what answers were chosen and
by the way
um this is a multiple choice question
if you can find one that is not multiple
choice
i think i think everything in this set
is multiple choice
but you can even if the question is not
multiple choice
it will tell you what students typed in
as their answer
so this kind of information is fantastic
and you can use it
um as you please now in the you know the
setting that we're in remote learning
it's not
it's not going to be easy and you have
to find your way of
conveying that to your students whether
it be videos or or webinar
chat style things
video chats i should say but the
information is there to help you make
those decisions and that's
that's the beauty that's what i love
about khan academy the most it really
helps me
by the way i have to give a shout out to
my co-teacher susie because gerard got
mentioned so
share the love far and wide um
yeah i think i think you just nailed
though i wanted to really echo that last
sentiment
which is i think a lot of teachers will
look at khan academy and say uh
this is just trying to replace the
teacher somehow just like put my
classroom on autopilot
it couldn't be farther from the truth
because really this is a tool
and the teachers who are using the best
are the ones who are using it to drive
their own teaching
to get more information to serve their
students better and if there's something
i want everybody to know is
and i've given presentations about khan
academy and how to use it
and one of the things i always say to
people when i present is don't
necessarily use it the way i do okay
take what i do and make it your own you
know
here's how i do it i'm not saying it's
right by the way i'm not saying i've got
it figured out
because there's there's changes i make
with susie by the way susie and i
are big khan academy users uh we get
together and talk all the time i liked
how we did this maybe we should do that
instead
so um make it your own make it something
that you can use the information on
there to help you be a better teacher
it is not there to teach your students
for you now the videos in a time like
this
yeah they might be there to teach your
students because you can't be there
24 7. um and it's great
you know to be able to rewind and pause
and you know
sal khan in one of his ted talks talks
about how his cousin said they like him
better in his videos than in person and
he kind of said you know once you get
past the backhanded nature of that
comment
he goes they don't feel like they're
bothering the video of me because they
can pause they can rewind they can do
things
so it is just another tool um for me
my the way i use it you hear me i talk
about the exercises
and i want it to be that the students um
use the exercises sorry you use the
exercise data
to decide what it is my students need
cool and let me actually ask you one
final question here shalom before we
wrap
um tying into this question of like
looking at student scores figuring out
what they need
i know that a lot of the pressure is
offered this year in terms of state
assessments
but if we want to continue to use
assessments just to keep track of how
students are doing
are there any recommendations you have
this is a question from kelly by the way
to use khan academy to inform the
assessments you're doing
you know i i
we talked about this before i i don't
have a great answer
to that um because the khan academy
um assessments are really not
to me they're not they're not summative
assessments they're
they're formative so i look at it not as
like
okay here's a one-time assessment and
let's see what the kids know i look at
it more as an
ongoing set of data for me we're working
on
negative numbers addition and
subtraction and oh by the way a bunch of
my kids are struggling with absolute
value to find distance
it happens all the time that's a very
difficult skill right um
so i use it on an ongoing basis to make
formative assessment decisions
as i teach i don't really think
that it is a good assessment tool
not that it's a bad but it's not
necessarily designed to be an assessment
tool that like at the end
of or middle of the year let's give the
kids this okay now i know what they need
to you know
let's focus more on this or that it's
more of an ongoing assessment tool if
that makes sense
absolutely because students are
constantly getting feedback on how
they're doing
you're receiving those same reports on
your side use that to empower your
students empower you as an educator
not to be the final word about how your
students did um
speaking of final words any final words
of wisdom shalom as
american educators head out for another
big week of uh
preparation next week other than um
you know don't be jealous of the headset
uh now i understand that
i know you're frustrated right now and i
know the last thing you need is somebody
saying hey you should use this hey you
should use that
you know every website out there is like
yeah we're giving this for free now and
this is for free
right but they're going to go and when
this is all said and done
they're going to go and say hey remember
that thing we gave you for free it's
gonna it's gonna go away now
your district or you're gonna have to
pay for it and it's gimmicky
khan academy if if there's one thing
about it
it is not a gimmick it is based on
research
mastery based learning i think is the
way to
truly it's the way we learn everything
we learn how to ride a bike we learn how
to play an instrument we learn how to do
everything
by practicing until we're good at it and
this is the kind of thing that i know
it's hard to think of like oh my god i'm
going to
dive into something now but if you do
um you're going to see the benefits of
it and you might not use it anything
like i do it might be completely
different for you
all right i i don't expect people to do
it the way i do it
but you dive into it like i said
give the kids a few exercises see where
the data takes you see where the
information you get takes you so i
i wish everybody good luck and make sure
to join the teachers
page i don't know if i said that before
on facebook
you know um teach or khan academy
teachers page or teach with khan
there's a lot of ambassadors and just
otherwise experienced khan academy
teachers on there that
um are gonna they're they're happy to
answer your questions because they
they've been in the same position as you
they've been at the point where they
didn't understand something so um
you know go on there ask some questions
that's amazing all right well i will
include that in the chat section
um as mentioned before if we didn't get
to your question today my apologies
um please just submit it right here
which i've shared through the chat line
to get help
within a few hours from our amazing
customer support team and then finally
a huge shout out to shalom for sharing
his expertise today
i know it's a lot on our shoulders at
the moment but i feel like you've eased
our burden a little bit
and given us reason to be confident
about the future so thank you shalom
thank you for having me and good luck
everybody have a great one everyone